foreign
Bragg hey Ned what's up
better than I deserve how can we help
hey so um here's my situation
um basically what happened was uh I've
been in the Army a few years during that
time my wife and I got married we've had
two kids uh we bought a property
and uh eventually we moved out of that
property and we now live on post
um we rent the property and we make
about 400 a month on it now I'm getting
out of the army very soon in the next
few months
um we've hit a bit of a rough patch with
our finances and we're wondering if we
should sell the house or not to help us
transition out of the military into
civilian life yes
okay
thank you for your service but a rental
property here here's how I made that
decision and how all of us at Ramsey
process this
I always reverse engineer it
and uh then that usually gives me the
answer very quickly and the end so by
that I mean let's pretend you did not
own that rental property what how much
cash would I put in your pocket if you
sold it
uh there's about 100K left on the
property and on the Internet it's valued
at 175. okay so let's call it 50 Grand
or so okay you're gonna put fifty
thousand dollars cash in the middle of
your kitchen table
in your situation today if you did not
own the rental property and you had 50
000 cash in the middle of your kitchen
table would you go buy a rental property
and the answer very quickly is no
yep now no no because you're
transitioning and you're going through a
rough patch both
right transitioning out of the military
and you're going through a rough patch
with your finances not a time to use
your 50 grand for a rental property you
need to use it to make this transition
proper and to clean up some of the mess
that's causing the rough patch
does that make sense that's how I did
yeah you know thank you for your service
what are you going to do
I'm looking at some options it looks
like I'm probably going to be a prison
guard or a cop
okay
very cool well Christina's husband it's
been a while in law enforcement she
knows something about that yeah he
recently retired after 17 years so it's
been an amazing career for him yeah yeah
I hope it works out for me too yeah it's
quite the adventure you'll have some
really interesting stories at the end of
it all
right good for the grandkids yeah that's
exactly right hey thanks for your
service but that's uh that's a good way
to do that that's that thing we call
sunk cost analysis where you say you
know doesn't really matter how you got
here you're here
and if you weren't here would you put
yourself back here meaning that okay I
don't want to sell this uh investment
I'm going to wait till it comes back up
that's not how you analyze it
you know the question is if you wouldn't
buy that investment again today based on
everything you know about that
investment based on the economy based on
whatever then you shouldn't be owning it
today yeah you should get out of it yeah
yeah and it's good to just have that
reframe because then you can look at
that fifty thousand dollars and say okay
what is the best strategy for this money
what can we do to dig out of this hole
and kind of get a little bit of a head
start and it helps me to just pile it up
visually in the middle of the table just
have like a pile of 100 bills there
fifty thousand dollars worth of them
well and you go you know what would I
really do with that and um you know
sometimes that's a boat sitting in the
driveway that nobody has had in the
water for three years and you go uh time
to sell the boat
because if I didn't own the boat today I
wouldn't buy it today and if it's worth
eleven thousand dollars or whatever it
is I had eleven thousand dollars piled
up in the middle of the table would I
buy a boat no I hadn't put the stupid
thing in the water in three years or of
course I'd buy a boat we use it every
weekend you know and so yeah then you'd
keep the boat you can do that with
anything right well sometimes it's
things that are a bit more painful and
more painful situations like we have a
lot of people on the debt-free stage
that sold their truck their beloved
truck and it's like they did see that
visual representation of I love my truck
but that thirty thousand dollars or that
forty thousand dollars that I made that
I shouldn't that I shouldn't have spent
that money on could be a pile of money
on the table that we could use towards
debt we would rather you know at this
point I love my truck but I love debt
free more yep and that's that's what
you're saying when you sell the truck
yep that's what you're saying uh I
remember one of the first times that
happened I had a a good old boy in one
of our FPU classes a big hunter at a big
collection of guns and a huge collection
of uh collect knives it was a wonderful
knife collection and he was a great big
old guy you know and he comes in and his
little tiny wife is sitting there in the
we're in the class and Financial Peace
University we're having a discussion
afterwards you know in the small group
discussion and she starts crying and I'm
like what's wrong and she goes
my husband who sold his knife collection
to get us out of that wow it's the most
manly thing I've ever seen in my life
that he put his family ahead of his
little thing you know and his wife just
she you know she loved him before but
when he stepped up and took care of the
family and her before he took care of
his own little thing it just you know
their their marriage went to a whole
other level wow and so um I'll never
forget her crying because I mean I grew
up with a bunch of guys that I know what
that knife collection meant to that guy
some of you are like you don't
understand that was that was like that
was like taking off one of his little
toes I mean you know I was like it was a
big deal it's so easy to Breeze over
those stories and just be like oh yeah
they sold their their motorcycle or
their knife collection and and just kind
of see it as part of the process but
like to do that is I mean I have seen
some of the guys standing on the stage
look like they got punched in the
stomach when they admit that they sold
their truck or something like that but I
mean way to go for doing that because
that's just that is love that is
commitment that says a lot that's
exactly what it takes